[Music]
by 2050
the world's population is expected to
soar to almost 10 billion people
and two-thirds of us will live in cities
space will be at a premium
high rise offers a solution but concrete
and steel the materials we currently use
to build high
have a large carbon footprint an answer
might lie
in a natural material we've used for
millennia
our view is that all buildings should be
made of timber
we think that we should be looking at
concrete and steel
like we look at petrol and diesel
i think it's very realistic to think
that someone will build a wooden
skyscraper in the coming years
there's a lot of potential that's
unrealized for using timber at a very
large scale
[Music]
throughout history buildings have been
made of wood
but it has one major drawback it acts as
kindling
fire has destroyed large swathes of some
of the world's great cities
but by the early 20th century the era of
modern steelmaking had arrived steel was
strong
could be molded into any shape and used
to reinforce concrete
it allowed architects to build higher
than ever before
so why after more than a century of
concrete and steel
are some architects proposing a return
to wood
if concrete were to arrive as a new
material on dragon's den
if you were to pitch it and say i've got
this brand new material it's
liquid and you can pour it into any
shape and it'll solidify
that sounds great but then when you say
but we need a whole new fleet of
trucks to move it around and actually
when it solidifies it's not strong
enough we have to stick this other stuff
in it called
steel i don't think it would be a
compelling case
concrete and steel are costly to produce
and heavy to transport
wood however can be grown sustainably
and it's lighter than concrete
and crucially as trees grow they absorb
carbon dioxide from the air
locking it into the timber one study
showed that using wood to construct a
125 metre skyscraper
could reduce the building's carbon
footprint by up to 75 percent
regular timber isn't malleable like
steel or concrete and it isn't strong
enough to build high
but engineers have come up with a
solution it's called cross-laminated
timber
or clt for short it's basically a new
material
even though the underlying material is
something we've used for
millennia it's cross laminated so the
layers of wood are glued
at 90 degrees to each other and that
makes for a very very
stable material clt
is light and it's comparable in strength
to concrete and steel
but how does it cope when burnt with a
high heat source
the charred wood is extremely insulating
that's the tree's natural protection
against a forest fire
it chars it loses some of its structural
mass
but when you remove the source of flame
it extinguishes itself when
steel gets hot it gets a bit softer
we've actually seen some steel roofs
collapse
in fires where wooden roofs have not
london architects war thistleton are
already designing buildings with this
new kind of timber
there's a clt building behind where the
timber building sits behind timber clad
and then there's a really simple
galvanized steel walkway
cross-laminated timber is a material
that we work with a lot
once these panels arrive on site we're
building you know a floor a week
at least so this is incredibly fast this
is maybe twice as fast as concrete
because when you build a concrete
building what we call concrete buildings
are actually floor slabs and columns
when we build a cross-laminated timber
building
it's we're building floor slabs all the
external walls all the internal walls
the lift cores the stairs the stair
everything's made of timber so these are
like honeycomb structures
andrew and his colleagues designed
britain's first high-rise wooden
apartment block
and have recently completed the world's
largest timber-based building
behind these bricks is a timber core
made from more than 2
000 trees sourced from sustainable
forests
and this london practice is not alone in
advocating the use of clt
ambitious wooden high-rise buildings are
also being constructed
in scandinavia central europe and north
america
as yet nobody has used clt to build
beyond
55 meters but michael ramage's research
center in cambridge
working with another london practice has
proposed a concept design
of a 300 meter tower to be built on top
of one of london's most iconic concrete
structures
the barbican the way we've engineered
the oakwood towers to look at the
the global structure and is it stable
and would it stand up
and we believe the answer is yes the
columns at the base of the oakwood tower
would be about 2.5 meters square so
that's
solid timber made of small elements
glued together
[Music]
i think we'll probably see incremental
increases from the current height of
about
50 meters and at some point someone will
make a step change
probably to about 100 meters
making that jump in height will be a
difficult sell
the cost of building wooden skyscrapers
is largely unknown
but those costs could be reduced by
prefabricating large sections of
buildings in factories
and city dwellers will need to be
persuaded that clt
does not burn like ordinary wood as an
attractive natural material
wood is already popular for use in low
buildings
if planners approve it could rise to new
heights
you